et on retrouve donc gilbert casasus
professeur d'études européennes à
l'université bilingue de fribourg pour
décrypter justement cette votation
suisse qui a adopté cette nouvelle loi
contre le terrorisme
en quoi susciter la polémique sachant
que d'autres pays européens appliquent
déjà cette cette nouvelle loi qui je le
rappelle pourra en prévention en tout
cas assigné à résidence des présumés
terroristes en eau
alors d'abord parce que je pense que le
public français ne connaît pas du tout
la délégation suisse il faut tenir
compte d'une réalité
vous avez vu la conseillère fédérale mme
karin keller sutter et les ministres de
la justice et police ce qui paraît un
peu curieux de voir que les deux
compétences justice et police sont
regroupés et tout simplement elle est
permise de la police mais la police est
d'ordre cantonales et donc elle est à
elle un ministère ou la moitié de son
ministère elle a quasiment aucun pouvoir
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
et 7 nuls ou notation dont je respecte
évidemment le résultat mais où je ne
suis pas du tout d'accord c'est une loi
qui n'aurait pas dû être votée à mon
avis c'est tout simplement pour faire
semblant pour prouver que la suisse se
met au diapason de la lutte
antiterroriste mais là je voudrais aussi
qu'il ya clairement quelque chose de
fondamental la suisse a un système
démocratique qui fonctionne
il ya certes des mouvements populistes
n'aime pas le terme par exemple partie
ou dc l'union démocratique du centre qui
est un parti réactionnaire mais
contrairement à ce qui se passe en
france la démocratie puis-je n'est pas
en danger
en france elle est en danger si marine
le pen devait devenir présidente là il y
aurait un danger démocratique en france
il n'y a pas de danger démocratique en
suisse la suisse est un pays de la
droite c'est clair c'est un pays qui de
temps en temps prendre des mesures au
cours assez coercitive et assez
répressive comme ça a été le cas hier
il n'y a pas de danger pour la
démocratie en suisse contrairement à ce
qui pourrait se passer en france l'année
prochaine si c'est la question d'aller
danger la démocratie en tout cas il ya
une peur du terrorisme
en suisse comme en france alors là où si
raison garder ce n'est pas du tout la
même situation nous n'avons pas du tout
la même composante au niveau de la
population les questions démographiques
les questions religieuses sont
différentes en france qu'il n'y a pas de
tradition laïque en suisse
donc là aussi il faut prendre un certain
recul
il y a deux attentats ou tentatives
d'attentât en suisse la côté de lausanne
autres à lugano mais ce sont des
mouvements qui sont restés relativement
sporadiques il me semblerait mais alors
là évidemment du pas bien placé parce
que qui simplement les services secrets
le sable il ne semblerait pas qu'il y
ait de véritables groupes terroristes
qui se soit installée en suisse
l'intérêt politique du terrorisme des
terroristes n'est pas le même en france
qu'il ne l'est en suisse et dont il faut
surtout pas là aussi faire des
confusions
ce qui est regrettable et je ne peux que
vous répétez c'est qu'une telle loi qui
à mon avis ne s'imposait pas a été voté
par 56% de la population qu'un taux de
participation pour la suisse
relativement élevé 56 % c'est clair je
m'attendais même un résultat un peu
supérieurs parce que dès qu'on parle de
terrorisme les citoyens se dit bah oui
il faut prendre des mesures important
qu'il faut prendre des mesures
répressives
on sait que ces lois on peut faire
toutes les lois du monde contre le
terrorisme vous savez par rapport aux
fanatiques par rapport à des gens qui
sont liés à cette idéologie c'est pas
les lois qui les arrête
c'est pas du tout comme par la loi que
l'on peut véritablement combattre le
terrorisme c'est tout à fait par
d'autres moyens
la crainte des opposants à cette loi
c'est justement une définition peu
claires du terrorisme puisque ils
craignent que des activistes ne soit
visé par par cette loi on pourrait
arrêter préventivement des gens qui ne
sont pas forcément prêts où il n'y
aurait pas de preuve en tout cas de leur
culpabilité alors les créations
totalement fondée mais il y a aussi
quelque part en suisse
même si je fus très critique de temps en
temps par par rapport au régime de ce
pays mais homophobie il n'y a pas de
crainte démocratique avoir ensuite
concernant la france c'est que il ya une
sorte de raison c'est à dire que si on
dépasser certaines limites je pense que
là les suisses ne l'accepterai pas c'est
à dire très intéressant dans toute
l'histoire de la suisse
il ya toujours eu des mouvements très à
droite qui ont flirté parfois avec
l'extrême droite
mais et c'est je ne peux que me répéter
la suisse n'a jamais franchi le pas il
n'y a jamais eu de pépins en suisse et
il n'y a pas de le pen en suisse donc
c'est là clairement une différence
fondamentale
la suisse est une démocratie bourgeoise
c'est à dire comme on dit en spitz et
cape town de droite libéral
économiquement qui est acide défaut
qu'il ya des nombres défaut la votation
qui m'a le plus énervé hier s'est passé
sur le terrorisme mais c'est le reçues
sur la loi du co2 qui voulait permettre
à la suisse d'adopter les décisions prix
à paris en 2004 ça a été refusé par le
comte majorité mais ça a été refusé
et ça je trouve ça beaucoup plus
préoccupant pour la suisse que c'est toi
de chaos risque et je vous répète que
personnellement avez combattu que je
trouve fausse car elle ne réglera en
rien du tout le problème du terrorisme
en suisse quand bien même on peut parler
de terrorisme en suisse car ce n'est pas
comparable du pays comme la france ou la
grande-bretagne ou la belgique ou cetera
merci beaucoup gilbert et casas eu de
nous avoir livré votre point de vue ce
matin en direct dans la matinale de rtl
france